spesso ci viene detto intimato imposto
di nasconderci di non vivere nella
nostra vita serenamente però più delle
volte le motivazioni che ci vengono date
solo un pochino da stronzi guarda da
un'altra parte
se per te non ho mai visto due sposi
uscire da una chiesa di nascosto
se non riesce a parlare con tuo figlio
il problema è tuo e poi se non riesce a
spiegare una cosa semplice come la mura
tuo figlio cosa farai quando dovrei
parlare gli di odio se ti mette così
tanta ansia parlargli diversità come
varare nel momento in cui dovrai
spiegargli che ci sono bambini che
muoiono di fame per via della guerra ci
sono bambini che vengono amati da
piccoli e oggetti da grande
[Applauso]